josh if you want to cue that up i think
people are really eager to see some
gameplay
let's take a look let's see how this
game is looking currently on xbox one
sporting down
sam clearly we're looking at a little
slayer match here on bizarre
one of our new maps there's a lot to
take in i'm sure for viewers who are
just
seeing a lot of stuff for the first time
here yeah i can't i can't remember
if we've shown things like the false car
line being used i think it was weekly
shown in the multiplayer trailer and i
think this is the first time we've shown
first person view of someone walking
around in bazaar
i think it has we're also right now kind
of getting a look at the friend info
system
that we've discussed on some of our
blogs in the past this is
kind of moving away from forcing players
into red and blue allows us to kind of
maintain that unique armor customization
that's become a
greater focal point for halo infinite
yeah and i think this is a this is a
pretty good example of that and i think
you're really seeing those colors pop
out on the xbox one hardware
that's great i think i just noticed a
custom skin applied to that ar there
that we saw briefly
i missed it unfortunately i do love that
oh yeah
i love the ar skins it's kind of nice
being able to customize your starting
weapon
it's the one you're going to see most
often so i like to have mine uh
now internally from a development play
test perspective i mean obviously we've
got the teams focusing on all platforms
and all builds and safe to say that that
we've got
folks truly getting sweaty on durango on
xbox series x and s
and low med medium and high pc specs as
well right
yeah so obviously as i said before we
can't cover every
pc spec out there but we try to have a
good range within our testing
and we have folks playing on xbox ones
regularly myself included
i try and play test on xbox one as much
as possible
so because it's a really important thing
for us to support make sure it's looking
good
yeah it really it really is awesome that
we're able to kind of
bring that audience forward with us
right and we know there's there's
obviously a large amount of xbox one
players out there
especially as you know frankly some
people i think are still eager to
acquire a new console and
with some of the supply chain issues
that have come around during the
pandemic
not necessarily easy for everyone so
you know thankfully i'm not one of the
engineers i can't imagine it's
necessarily a trivial undertaking to be
able to scale so so smartly across
different hardware but
i gotta say shaping up super super nice
and really looking forward to getting
some feedback from xbox one players
after this weekend yeah absolutely
so that's i think that's going to wrap
up that clip that we have now we're
going to show a little more gameplay
here in a bit
um we're going to have tom french our
multiplayer associate creative director
join us we have another match from xbox
series x that we're going to get into
but once this wraps up we're going to
jump back over to the build and we're
going to look through this real flight
build here
by the way i i heard you're a real
neither fan is that true